الدفاع الامريكيه تكشف عن حارس الرخاء
متعدد الجنسيات لحمايه البحر الاحمر
والحوثيون يردون بحزم وتل ابيب تعلن
جاهزيتها لهدني في القطاع فيما روسيا تدعو
الى تنفيذ قرار مجلس الامن الطائرات
الرخيصه للفصائل تتفوق على الجيش العبري
عالي التقنيه تل ابيب تبلغ واشنطن بشرط
دبلوماسي قد يضع حدا للتوترات المستمره
على الحدود اللبنانيه ومصر تعلن حقها في
الدفاع امام اثيوبيا البنتاجون يبلغ
الكونجرس الامريكي بموعد نفاد الاموال
المخصصه لاوكرانيا والمخابرات الامريكيه
يتعين على القاده الغربيين الاستماع
بعنايه الى ما يقوله بوتين اوكرانيا ترسل
عملائها السريين الى موسكو والرد الروسي
لا
يتاخر الهدنه
تقترب البدايه من البحر الاحمر فقد اعلن
وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستن عن تشكيل
قوه متعدده الجنسيات سميت حارس الرخاء
لحمايه التجاره بالبحر الاحمر في اعقاب
هجمات الحوثيين وافاد اوستون بان هذه
العمليه تجمع عده دول تشمل المملكه
المتحده والبحرين وكندا وفرنسا وايطاليا
وهولندا والنرويج وسيشمل
اسبانيا بالاضافه الى الولايات المتحده
بينما اجرى وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني
بلنك اص هاتفيا بنظيره السعودي فيصل بن
فرحان ندد فيه بهجمات الحوثيين على السفن
التجاريه في البحر الاحمر وحث المملكه على
التعاون بين جميع الشركاء لدعم الامن
البحري ليخرج عضو المكتب السياسي للحوثيين
محمد البخيتي ويؤكد انه رغم التهديدات
الامريكيه فان العمليات العسكريه في البحر
الاحمر لن تتوقف الا بتوقف الحرب في
القطاع واضاف الحوثيون ان تشكيل الولايات
المتحده تحالفا دوليا للتصدي لهم في الممر
الملاحي الدولي لن يمنعه من استهداف السفن
المتجهه الى تل ابيب وها هو المصدر يتحدث
اعلنت جماعه الحوثي انها لن توقف ما اسمته
بالعمليات العسكريه في البحر الاحمر وقال
مسؤول حوثي ان تشكيل الولايات المتحده
تحالفا دوليا للتصدي لها في الممر الملاحي
الدولي لن يمنعها من استهداف السفن
المتجهه الى اسرائيل فيما صرح عضو المجلس
السياسي الاعلى للحوثيين محمد العلي
الحوثي بان الولايات المحده حاولت التواصل
مع صنعاء عده مرات الامر الذي قابلناه
بالرفض لانه لا يشرفنا وفق قوله غط الحرب
يجبر الاطراف على تراجع هنا قال الرئيس
العبري اسحاق هرتسوغ متحدثا الى سفراء
اجانب لدى تلبيب انهم جاهزون لهنه انسانيه
جديده وزياده المساعدات الانسانيه في
القطاع مقابل اطلاق سراح الرهائن وها نحن
نتصفح المصدر
امامكم
[موسيقى]
بينما اعلن مندوب روسيا الدائم لدى الامم
المتحده فاصيل نيبينزيا ان روسيا تدعو الى
تنفيذ قرار مجلس الامن الدولي الداعي الى
هده انسانيه في القطاع وخلال المعارك
اعلنت الفصائل انها جددت قصفه الابي برشقه
صاروخيه ردا على المجازر بحق المدنيين في
القطاع وافادت قناه الجزيره عن سماح اصوات
انفجارات واعتراضات لصواريخ في سماء مدينه
تل ابيب الكبرى لينقل موقع بلومبرج عن
رئيس الشركه التي تزود تلبيب بالطائرات
المسيره قوله ان الحرب مع الفصائل تعتبر
بمثابه دعوه للجيوش للانتباه وتطوير
امكاناتها الفتاكه وقال الموقع انما وصفها
بطائرات الفصائل الرخيصه تفوقت على الجيش
العبري عاليه التقنيه كما اعتبر الموقع ان
استخدام الطائرات المسيره التجاريه
المجهزه بالقنابل كشف ثغرات في الدفاعات
العبريه من جانبه صرح المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كوربي بان
الولايات المتحده تفرق بين الضحايا
المدنيين في القطاع وفي اوكرانيا وقال لم
نرى اي دليلا على ان تل ابيب تقتل اشخاصا
ابرياء بشكل متعمد واعتبر ان روسيا تبتغي
ذلك في اوكرانيا مضيفا انه ولذلك يمكن
مقارنه تكتيكاتها بتكتيكات الفصائل في
سياق اخر استقبل الجانب الفلسطيني من معبر
رفح 60 شاحنه تحمل مساعدات انسانيه واغاثه
ومستلزمات طبيه ووقود اضافه الى غاز للطهي
وتستعد السلطات المصريه في المعبر لتسيير
دفعه مساعدات انسانيه جديده الى القطاع
عبر معبري العوجه وكرم ابو سالم وعلى
الحدود اللبنانيه اعلنت مقاومه لبنان ان
مقاتليها استهدفوا موقع المطل العسكري
العبري قباله القطاع الشرقي من جنوب لبنان
وحققوا اصابات مؤكده وافادت وسائل اعلام
بان طائرات ومسيرات عبريه شنت غارات على
منطقه اللبونه ومحيط بلدتي مارون الراس
وعلم الشعب كما استهدفت محيط بلدات الخيام
وكفر كالا وحولا
ويارونق موقع اكسيوس ان تلبيب ابلغت
واشنطن برغبتها في ابعاد المقاومه
اللبنانيه نحو 10 كيلومترات عن الحدود مع
لبنان باتجاه شمالي الليطاني معتبره ان
هذا الشرط جزء من اتفاق دبلوماسي محتمل قد
يضع حدا للتوترات المستمره في حرب اخرى
ذكرت وكاله رويترز ان الاردن شن غارات
جويه داخل الاراضي السوريه على طول دوده
ضد مخابئ لمهربي المخدرات وقال المرصد
السوري ان الغاره الاردنيه ادت الى مقتل
تجري مخدرات اثر ضربه جويه في محافظه
السويداء جنوبي سوريا وكان الجيش الاردني
اعلن مقتل واصابه عدد من المهربين واعتقال
تسعه اخرين بحوزتهم مخدرات واسلحه بعد
اشتباكات مستمره على الحدود مع سوريا
ولنات كم بالمصدر يعني هذه الحادثه منذ
فجر يوم امس كان هنالك اشتباك على الحدود
الاردنيه ما بين مجموعات مسلحه وقوات حرس
الحدود الاردنيه هذه الاشتباكات ما زالت
حتى مساء اليوم مستمره كما قال بيان
للقوات المسلحه الاردنيه في مصر اعلنت
وزاره الرا انتهاء الاجتماع الرابع
والاخير من مسار المفاوضات على سد النهضه
بين مصر والسودان واثيوبيا دون تحقيق
نتائج نظرا لاستمرار ذات المواقف
الاثيوبيه بسبب تمادي اثيوبيا وتراجعها عن
التفاهمات فيما اكدت القاهره انها سوف
تراقب كثب عمليه ملء وتشغيل سد النهضه وان
مصر تحتفظ بحقها المكفول بموجب المواثيق
الدوليه للدفاع عن امنها المائي والقومي
في حاله تعرضه
للضرر تاريخ
الانتهاء كل دعم لابد ان ينتهي ليس هناك
من يستمر بالدعم الى ما لا نهايه هنا ذكرت
وكاله بلومبرج نقلا عن رساله من المراقب
المالي للبنتاغون مايكل ماكورد لاعضاء
الكونجرس الامريكي ان اموال وزاره وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه لامداد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه ستنفد في ال 30 من ديسمبر وهذه
هي المره الاولى التي تحدد فيها وزاره
الدفاع الامريكي الموعده الدقيقه لاستنفاذ
الموارد لدعم كياف على ذات السياق نقل
موقع بزنس انسايدر ان الاوكران ورجال
الاعمال الغربيين يخشون من امكانيه سرقه
مساعدات الغرب التي تبلغ قيمتها مليارات
الدولارات لاوكرانيا من خلال نظام الفساد
الجديد الذي انشاه رئيس مكتب زيلينسكي
اندريه ارماك اثناء الصراع مع روسيا ليصرح
ضابط الاستخبارات الامريكي السابق سكوت
ريتر بانه يتعين على القاده الغربيين
الاستماع بعنايه الى ما يقوله الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين من اجل فهم موقف
روسيا واشار ريتر الى ان الرئيس اكد مرارا
ان روسيا لا تخطط لمهاجمه دول النيتو
ويتوقع ان تعود العلاقات مع الدول
الاوروبيه الى طبيعتها هناك اكد الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بان الجيل الحالي
من السياسيين الاوروبيين لا يستطيع ان يقف
في وجه امريكا بسبب تبعيه هم الهائله لها
فيما صرحت صحيفه ديلي اكسبرس البريطانيه
بان تقليص حجم العمليه العسكريه للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه كان بمثابه ضربه قويه
لرئيس اوكرانيا فلاديمير زيلينسكي واشارت
الصحيفه الى ان القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
تعاني من نقص كبير في الذخيره بسبب عدم
قدره الحلفاء الغربيين على امداد اوكرانيا
بالذخيره اللازمه بشكل مستمر من جانبه
افاد الرئيس الاوكراني زيلنسكي بان الجيش
عرض عليه تعبئه من 4 50 الى 500 الف شخص
اضافي في قوات الدفاع مضيفا ان هذا رقم
خطير للغايه في موسكو صرح مدير جهاز الامن
الفيدرالي الروسي الكساندر بورتنيكوف ان
نظام كياف على خلفيه الاخفاقات العسكريه
بدا في تكثيف كفاحه السري وارسال عملاء
ومخربين الى روسيا وقال انه باخذ هذا في
الاعتبار فنحن بالطبع نقوم بالعمل اللازم
والتدابير اللازمه لتحديد الهويه بالطبع
نود ان نفعل كل شيء للعمل بشكل استباقي
نحن ننجح في هذا بشكل عام ميدانيا افادت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بان خسائر القوات
الاوكرانيه بلغت نحو 680 جنديا في محاور
عده خلال 24
ساعه